the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we're going to conclude our
study of vectors as applied to motion in
the plane now recall that for the last
two units we were discussing polar
coordinates so today what we would like
to do is investigate what velocity and
acceleration vectors would have looked
like had we elected to pick
representative vectors in terms of polar
coordinates now what do we mean by
representative vectors
we mean of course analogs of I and J
just like T and n in tangential and
normal components were parallels to I
and J let's take a look and see what
that means here we call today's lecture
vectors and polar coordinates the idea
is that we're given a curve C which we
have for some reason or other elected to
express in terms of polar coordinates
the polar equation of the curve C is R
equals f of theta a typical point on the
curve C would be called R comma theta
say where theta was the Angle made by
the horizontal and the radius vector and
R was the distance from the origin to
the point now what we're saying is that
in terms of polar coordinates a very
natural vector to pick especially if we
think later in terms of a central force
fields that we've talked about earlier
the idea that there may be a force that
has its line of actions from the origin
to the point on the curve a very natural
vector to choose is the vector that we
elect to call u sub R and what that
vector is apparently is the vector one
unit long having the direction of the
radius vector R so here is U sub R over
here if we think of U sub R as playing
the role of I then the vector which
plays the role of J should be a positive
90 degree rotation of U sub R and we
elect to call that vector u sub
theta using the theta here more to
indicate the fact that we're using polar
coordinates than to indicate anything
about the angle theta itself in other
words notice that u sub theta by
definition is just a positive 90 degree
rotation of U sub R where u sub R is a
unit vector in the direction of the
radius vector now if we want to see this
in terms of I and J components what
we're saying is that u sub R is a unit
vector whose I component is what since
this angle here is also theta its I
component this cosine theta and it's J
component the sine theta so u sub R is
cosine theta I plus sine theta J u sub
theta and I'm going to do a little twist
here that I didn't do in the T and n
components just to show you another
approach rather than to start with
derivatives or anything like this notice
that what we know about U sub theta is
that it's obtained by from u sub R by a
positive 90 degree rotation of theta so
that means if I replace theta in the
expression for u sub R by theta plus 90
degrees that should give me u sub theta
if I now remember my trigonometric
identities that tells me that u sub
theta is minus sine theta I plus cosine
theta J by the way if we now look at
this expression and compare it with the
expression for u sub R we see at once
that u sub theta is the derivative of U
sub R with respect to theta and notice
as we said before that part of this
should have been known to us by now
namely since u sub R varies with theta
but it has a constant magnitude we know
that the derivative of U sub R with
respect to theta has to be perpendicular
to u sub R in other words we knew that u
sub theta had to be either plus or minus
the derivative of U sub R with respect
to theta but now we have a direct way of
showing this and by the way going one
step further if we now differentiate u
sub theta with respect to theta we get
what minus cosine theta I
- sine theta J which is just minus U sub
R in other words if you differentiate u
sub R with respect to theta once you get
u sub theta just as we should if you
differentiate a second time you get
minus u sub R and therefore it appears
that the operation of differentiating
with respect to theta rotates u sub R by
90 degrees by the way I should mention
that I could have made all of these
remarks when we were studying tangential
and normal components in other words
that I just wrote this out here but this
was true with T and n but the point was
we did we never had to differentiate n
with respect to T to find the
acceleration vector a in other words
recall that the key step in using
tangential and normal vectors now I
mentioned this in a little bit more
detail later was that the velocity
vector was simply the SD T times the
unit tangent vector T the coefficient of
n was zero in polar coordinates notice
that V in general will have both a u sub
R and a u sub theta component therefore
to compute a I have to differentiate V
with respect to T that means among other
things I'm going to have to take the
derivative of U sub theta with respect
to T by the chain rule that's going to
be the same as taking the derivative of
U sub theta with respect to theta times
D theta DT but the important point is is
that someplace along the line in
studying kinematics and polar
coordinates I am going to have to
differentiate u sub theta with respect
to theta and just to show you again very
very quickly what I mean by this all I'm
saying is we already know in kinematics
that the velocity vector is always
tangential to the curve notice in this
particular diagram for example that if
you look at U sub R + u sub theta if you
think of a vector whose Direction is
tangent to the curve at this particular
point that vector will have in general
both au sub theta and they use of our
component in fact in this particular
diagram
I shouldn't say in general it
we'll have a you survive and they use
sub theta component okay so far so good
but now I want to make one little
caution a caution which is not at all
self-evident at least to me and which
gave me great difficulty myself when I
was a student and that is my feeling was
that U sub R was simply the unit vector
in the direction of our in fact I said
that earlier that u sub R was the unit
vector in the direction of the radius
vector R and this is one of the reasons
why even though professor Thomas and the
textbook doesn't make such an issue over
this why I am such a bug on using the
phrase sense as well as direction and
that is my claim is that the unit u sub
R the unit vector u sub R need not be
the radius vector R divided by the
magnitude of our it'll have the same
direction but watch what happens with
sense let me give you instead of talking
about this thing abstractly let me give
you a concrete example let's take the
curve which in polar coordinates has the
equation R equals cosine theta okay that
happened as you recall this would be
this particular circle here now let's
take theta to be 120 degrees if I use
our definition for u sub R which is
cosine theta I plus sine theta J and
replace theta by 120 degrees what I get
is is that u sub R is cosine 120 degrees
I plus sine 120 degrees J remember that
the cosine of 120 is minus 1/2 and the
sine of 120 is plus 1/2 the square root
of 3 u sub r turns out to be minus 1/2 I
plus 1/2 the square root of 3 J on the
other hand my claim is that when theta
is 120 degrees what point are we at the
curve you see if I take theta to be 120
degrees notice that when theta is 120
degrees R is negative 1/2 and that
therefore I'm at the point P 0 here
recall that by definition
are the radius vector is measured from
the origin to the point in other words
according to our previous definition
it's this vector which would be called
are but our definition says that it's
this vector which is U sub R and in fact
if you just check the figures that we've
obtained over here notice that u sub R
has its I component equal to minus 1/2
its J component being plus 1/2 the
square root of 3 therefore X is negative
y is positive but if X is negative and Y
is positive you're in the second
quadrant not the fourth quadrant you see
in other words u sub R is almost the
radius vector in fact it would have been
if the if in polar coordinates little R
happens to be positive in fact let me
summarize that in a different way let's
assume that we have a curve C whose
polar equation is R equals f of theta
then the idea is this if f of theta
happens to be at least as big as 0 then
u sub R is equal to the radius vector R
divided by its magnitude in other words
u sub R will be in the same direction as
the radius vector and by the way recall
this is just another way of saying R
what we're saying is again if we had
never let little R and polar coordinates
be negative no problem would have
occurred but we do let little R be
negative so we have to be a mite careful
the careful part comes in where if our
happens to be negative in which case u
sub R has the opposite sense of the
radius vector capital R which we saw in
the previous example in other words in
this case u sub R is minus the negative
of the radius vector divided by its
magnitude in what case is that if our
happens to be negative the important
point to notice however that in either
case the radius vector R is equal to the
parallel coordinate R times u sub R in
other words if R happens to be positive
these two vectors have the same sense if
our happens
the negative these two vectors have the
opposite sense in other words in either
case this expression is always correct
but the important thing to notice is
that the sense of U sub R is determined
by theta naught by r not by F of theta
okay at any rate once we have this
particular recipe established we can now
go ahead and study motion in the plane
namely notice that our radius vector R
is now given by the polar coordinate R
times u sub R well I guess I should say
here that I'm assuming that the equation
of motion is given by R is some function
of theta that's the R that I'm using in
here at any rate what is the velocity
vector by definition it's just the
derivative of the radius vector with
respect to time
that's just DDT of our times u sub R now
keep in mind that our and new sub R are
both functions of time namely the
distance of the particle from the origin
as well as the direction of the line of
action that joins the particle to the
origin will in general depends on time
consequently I must use the product rule
here I already know that I can use the
product rule for vector and/or scalar
functions and any combination thereof so
I just differentiate this thing with
respect to time I get what this is di DT
in other words the derivative first
times the second which is U sub R okay
plus the first times the derivative of
the second which is the derivative of U
sub R with respect to time now keep in
mind again there is nothing wrong with
this recipe but what I would like is to
have the velocity expressed in U sub R +
u sub theta components so far I haven't
expressed in terms of U sub R component
and a d u sub R DT component but now
here again is why the chain rule is so
important keep in mind that I already
know that if this expression here had
been the derivative of U sub R with
respect to theta instead of with respect
to T
what would this expression have been it
would have been you sub theta we saw
that earlier in the lecture no here's
what we do we say okay these aren't the
same but let's cross this out let's use
the chain rule and by the chain rule the
derivative of U sub R with respect to T
is the same as the derivative of U sub R
with respect to theta times D theta DT
and rewriting this so that becomes
legible we have that the velocity vector
is the ID T times u sub R plus our D
theta DT times u sub theta and again
notice that as far as u sub R and u sub
theta are concerned even if I did not
notice my subtlety and by the way I'm
going to leave this for the exercises
but even if I didn't notice the subtlety
that u sub R need not have the same
sense as the radius vector R notice that
if I did not try to draw this thing to
scale I can still get the license at the
scale but if I if I didn't try to graph
the answer here given our as a function
of theta and theta as a function of T
notice that the R DT and our D theta DT
are well-defined arithmetic ly with no
possible chance of making a geometric
mistake the place that you can make the
biggest mistake is if you automatically
think that u sub r must have the same
sense as capital R but as I say we'll
leave any additional discussion of that
for the exercises I should also point
out that when I first learned this
recipe myself it turned out that we were
ahead of the physics class was ahead of
the math class and we learnt this thing
in the physics class almost intuitively
in other words as a geometric aside
notice that if I'm given the curve and
say S indicates the direction of
increasing our plank here
what I could do is think of a little
differential region here namely his my
radius vector R and his my velocity
vector in the direction of U sub R then
I take a little increment of angle D
theta
and I now think of V sub theta which is
at right angles to V sub R as being
tangent to the circle I would have
obtained if I had imagined that this
particular point the particle was being
viewed with respect to the circle rather
than to the curve itself to make a long
story short what I'm driving at is that
physically it's very easy to justify
that the magnitude of the use of our
component of the velocity is the
magnitude of dr/dt how fast the radius
vector is changing instantaneously on
the other hand notice that for the u sub
theta component this arc length is given
in differential form by Rd theta if I
divide the arc length by the time which
is DT I get ID theta divided by DT which
leads to our D theta DT which is the
same expression that we got analytically
but the point that I want to bring out
here is that our derivation required no
geometrical physical insight the reason
I want to bring this out is I follow
this argument fine in my elementary
physics course the place I get hung up
is that the instructor that then went
into a fantastic hand waving type of
demonstration and showed us how the
acceleration look in terms of U sub R
and u sub theta components and actually
that was a blessing for me because it
was that day that I decided to become a
math major rather than a physics major
which was a blessing both for me and
society I guess but the thing that I
want to show you is that the beauty of a
mathematical approach is that we can now
obtain a the acceleration vector from
the velocity vector without having to
know any great physical insight in fact
we have to know no physical insight to
do this namely by definition a is the
derivative of the velocity vector with
respect to time we also have seen that
the velocity vector is the expression
that I have here in brackets so I have
to differentiate that with respect to
time notice that this is the sum of two
terms one of which is a product of two
factors and the other of which is a
product of three factors and
the way among other things to review
here this this is the first time in this
course that we have actually had to use
the product rule for a function a factor
a function consisting of three variable
factors even though we discussed this in
part one here is a case where in a real
life situation what we need is a product
the derivative rule for a product of
three functions at any rate this is done
in great detail in the text I do it more
in the notes so I'm just going to hit
the highlights here the point is I now
differentiate this sum term by term
namely to differentiate this I take the
derivative of the first term times the
second plus the first term times the
derivative of the second now to
differentiate this term I have to
differentiate a product of three factors
and recall and by the ways I told you in
part one whenever I say recall that
means if you don't recall it's my polite
way of saying look it up but to
differentiate a product of three
functions we write the product down
three times and each time differentiate
a different factor for example the first
time we'll differentiate R with respect
to t which is dr/dt
the second time we'll differentiate the
theta/dt with respect to t which is the
second derivative of theta with respect
to t and the third time we'll
differentiate u sub theta with respect
to t which is the derivative of u sub
theta with respect to t and summarizing
that what do I have here
I have di DT D theta DT times u sub
theta plus R d2 theta DT squared times u
sub theta plus R D theta DT times the
derivative of U sub theta with respect
to T now the point is that if I look at
these five terms some of them are in ice
form namely his a u sub R term is au sub
theta term
here's a u sub theta term but these
terms are sort of mongrelized namely
what I have to do here is utilize the
chain rule and remem
the derivative of U sub R with respect
to theta would have been u sub theta the
derivative of U sub theta with respect
to theta would have been minus u sub R
so by the chain rule you see what I'm
going to do is I'll replace each of
these terms by their chain rule
expression then I'll collect terms and
the reason I'm going over this fairly
rapidly is that it is a problem of sheer
mechanics but the punchline is that if I
now collect my terms the acceleration
vector has as its use of our component D
- R DT squared minus R D theta DT
squared and the u sub theta component is
our D - theta DT squared plus 2 D R DT D
theta DT and the beautiful part from my
point of view about all of this is if I
don't understand any physics at all this
particular result is valid it's
mathematically self-contained now
certainly there is no harm in a man who
understands physics well enough to say
look at this is the acceleration in the
radius direction alone and this is some
kind of a correction factor proportional
to the square of the angular velocity C
D theta DT being angular velocity and
what have you and go through this
particular thing I'm saying fine if you
can do that but notice the beauty this
complicated expression gives us use the
acceleration vector in terms of U sub R
+ u sub theta with no hand waving it's
mathematically self-contained by the way
keep in mind that one of the reasons
that we study polar coordinate motion is
the fact that in many cases we are going
to be dealing with a central force field
and the interesting thing is that in
central I'll just abbreviate this in a
central force situation this expression
is 0 C central force means what that the
force is in the radial direction that
means all of the acceleration if you're
using Newtonian physics F equals MA all
the acceleration is in the direction of
U sub R therefore
the component in the direction of U sub
theta must be zero so this fairly
complicated expression id2 theta dt
squared plus two the R DT D theta DT
equals zero becomes the fundamental
equation for central force field motion
but again we'll talk about that more in
the exercises what I wanted to do now
was to make what I think is a very
important summary and that is that when
we're studying the position vector R and
the velocity vector V and the
acceleration vector a that none of these
depend on the coordinate system it's
only their components that do in other
words at the expense of having a fairly
jumbled figure which I rationalized here
because it is small but I think it is
clear from context what I'm saying is
let's suppose I have a curve C and some
point p0 on this curve C I can draw in
the pair of orthogonal vectors I and J
in the plane I can draw in the pair of
orthogonal vectors u sub R orthogonal
means perpendicular if we haven't said
that before u sub R and u sub theta I
can draw those in and I can draw in t +
n now all I know is that if I have the
velocity vector V it must be tangential
to the curve hopefully by this time we
realize that the acceleration vector has
no such restriction let's just draw in a
V na call these the velocity vectors and
the acceleration vectors the point is
that V and a are determined by the
motion not by the coordinate system in
other words when we're talking about the
velocity of this particle at the point P
zero its velocity is the same no matter
what coordinate system we're using it
just happens that if we're dealing with
Cartesian coordinates the velocity
vector is the x dt i plus dy/dt J in
other words it's this particular
combination of I and J if we're using T
and n components the particular
combination of T and n is what the SD T
times the unit tangent vector
plus zero add and if we happen to be
using polar coordinates
look the expression is the ID T times u
sub R plus r d-theta dt u sub theta but
let me circle these because it's the
same velocity in each case we use this
when horizontal and vertical motion are
important we use this when we're
interested in motion along the curve and
we use this primarily in central force
fields but it makes no difference it's
the same velocity vector and in a
similar way it's also the same
acceleration vector whichever system you
happen to use namely if we use Cartesian
coordinates the acceleration vector is
the second derivative of x with respect
to t times i plus the second derivative
of Y with respect to T times J that same
vector if we express it in T and n
components is d to s DT squared times T
plus Kappa the curvature vector and the
curvature number times the s DT squared
times n and if we express it in terms of
polar coordinates as we just saw earlier
in our lecture this is the expression
that we get in other words then this
summarizes our study of motion in the
plane using either Cartesian or polar or
tangential and normal components you see
the point is that we pick whichever
coordinate system happens to be of the
greatest interest to us the greatest
value to us we make the coordinate
system our slave rather than the other
way around and tackle the problems from
that particular point of view at any
rate that ends this phase of our
particular course and in the next phase
of our course we get to probably what is
the most fundamental building block of
the entire course we get to that
particular topic which by and large most
courses and functions of several
variables begin with but we'll talk
about that more
the next time we meet and until that
time goodbye funding for the publication
of this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate